it makes me I'm obviously I'm devastated
to hear this and it also makes me very
angry very angry that the Russians
thought they could do this to a sport
that I love and they thought they could
get away with it that they have got away
with it for so long because it really
does hit hard to all of those athletes
who have competed for years here and I
think that now we have to have faith
that our sport can come through this and
can move forward I am heartened that it
is actually coming to light and they
haven't got away with it and we have to
move forward from here and make sure
that we go in a positive direction and
make the changes that need to be made I
do agree and the consequences I think
we've talked in the past about the fact
that Federation's should be banned if
it's shown that there's been systemic
and endemic doping going on and not
enough has been done against doping in
that country or if the number of
positives from a country surpasses a
certain amount then I believe there
should be sanctions at least against
that Federation and in this case that we
should go as far as banning them until
they can show that this that has been
going on for years is not going on
anymore but I think we also have to
stress that we're not just talking about
athletics here this issue has come to
light because still it was found out
from within athletics but it's all
sports in the report and I think that
that needs to be widespread going
forward into the Olympics next year in
the fact that it it's is systemic doping
probably as some people had feared but
on a much bigger scale and the level of
corruption that this was able to to
corrupt top levels of our sport and I do
believe that it is a small amount of
individuals there that were corrupt and
that we have the right person now in
charge to be able to clean that up and
move forward but the fact that it was
able to happen and that people were able
to do this to like I say a sport that I
love and a sport that I believe has a
lot so much good in it and a lot of
clean athletes who want to be able to go
out there and give it their best shot on
the world stage and the whole
anti-doping water
the International athletic federation we
have this right have this need to give
that right to clean athletes that they
can go out and compete on a level
playing field that they can know that
giving it their best shot will mean that
they know how good they are on that
level and they won't be coming up
against cheats and I do feel for
athletes who now find out that they
should have stood on that podium and
that's why I've been such a big advocate
for for lifetime bans for doping because
it is fraud and you are stealing a
moment from a clean athlete that they
can never ever get back and the I could
say if we're looking for positives in
all of this it is that it is coming to
light and that people aren't getting
away with it yes they might have got
away with it for too long and it's
devastating that it was going on at all
but it is coming to light and they
aren't getting away with it I think how
long it takes depends on how big the
scale is and that's still coming to
light but I do believe that that's one
of the reasons that back said so much to
get in as president and i do believe he
is the right man to do that moving
forward he's already talked about their
changes that it's going to be making for
independent and eat opeing bodies the
bigger investment in anti-doping it not
all of that and I think it needs more
than that needs more than the president
needs more than the Federation it needs
the athletes as well to stand up and say
yeah okay we we have to do something to
protect the sport that we love and to
make sure that we are competing on a
level playing field and maybe that means
pushing for bigger sanctions against
doping and against cheaters and also
just opening things up do we need to say
oh yeah okay as well as having the anti
doping test where we allow our homes to
be searched where we are now we sit
there mean I personally sit there and
take her and anti-doping sorry and I lie
detector test if that needs to be done
and just bigger steps bigger sanctions
and push for that